hi everyone uh my name is joe i'm
from miltoni biotech uh thanks for
tuning in to our webinar
this afternoon or i guess this morning
um
the lose track of time in this room um
in any case i'm going to be talking to
you a little bit about our
uh instrument the maximum title and how
it has
supported some groups making the
transition from uh
normal standard laboratory work into an
infectious
uh hazardous material type
application it seems like there's a lot
of people making that migration with the
rapid accumulation of coveted research
and i think we have a really unique
platform
that allows for um users to feel safe
with their operation on the the device
in a traditionally
quite uh open system type of
technology um myself i'm
from san diego area i went to graduate
school at uc san diego and did a lot of
cell sorting um on a an influx device
this is a
traditional jet and air sorter spent a
lot a lot of time
in a small windowless room with that
device
and after my phd came to miltoni
and have since learned a lot about where
still sorting fits
in the grand scheme of the science
community and
i've had the opportunity to work with a
lot of experts in a variety of different
fields
today we're going to focus mostly on the
the biohazardous element and
kind of that arena of cell sorting and
um i i think that's particularly
applicable to the
the kovid 19 landscape so um but
with that i will go ahead and jump into
this
um i from an agenda perspective i want
to
um kind of go through the the challenges
with this type of work
and um and really the advantages of
using something like self-sorting
technology but
uh it does come with caveats um i'll
give you a little bit of background on
our
sorting instrument the the title and
then
talk about how a couple of groups have
used that instrument and validated it
for
work with hazardous materials and then
kind of go over
a couple of applications that they've
actually been able to
run with it so um i'll look to stay on
time as best i can
and hopefully go through this in a
manner that
um even if you're new to the technique
or are new to the instrument that
we can hopefully have everybody pick up
something unique
so in the interest of that i'll start
very very broad
on really cell enrichment techniques and
i think anybody who's working in a cell
biology field immunology
um you've done some sort of cell
enrichment and that can be
um as trivial as an antibiotic selection
for an e coli culture or as specific as
a 15 color panel
looking for a very specific subset
um there are drawbacks to each of these
techniques and
um but we'll go into a little bit more
detail um
as many of you may know miltoni's real
flagship technology is
magnetic bead enrichment that has
started
almost it must be 30 years ago now
because it was 1989 i believe that the
patent came out
these are antibodies that are specific
for uh
antigens on cell types they are
conjugated to
iron oxide particles for magnetic
enrichment so we can pull out specific
cells
from a co-culture
and use those cells for downstream
assays
and this is a pretty much ubiquitous
technique now
and it's led to a pretty
amazing advancement in the clinical
applications in cellular
therapy as well which is really quite
exciting
this technique is magnetic enrichment
has the advantage of being
able to be done in a closed system which
has obvious implications for cellular
therapy and sterility but
in the context of today it has
particular benefit
in that it contains the material and
allows an operator to feel a lot more
comfortable working with
technology like that um
historically uh something like
fluorescence-based cell sorting or flow
cytometry sorting
um hasn't afforded that uh luxury
these are usually done in an
open environment something that uh
requires the cells to be passed through
the air
uh to be sorted effectively and uh
really
of all the flow space orders that are in
the field currently
uh it's got to be in a high 90 percent
of instruments that are
using this type of technology um so that
makes it really
quite difficult to scale that into
something that is
really approachable for a new operator
in this environment
because the the list of requirements to
feel
uh protected with an aerosol generating
system
uh is a long one and it's one that
requires uh really
quite a bit of expertise to feel ready
for um
so i'll go into a little bit more detail
on what that requirement
is but um i i think what we are going to
be really focusing on today
is not so much these bulk separation
strategies i think these are
well conserved i think people are
generally comfortable with the idea of
how these
uh can be implemented in a
environment with hazardous materials
but instead focus on flow-based sorting
flow cytometry sorting
and how this technology has
grown and adapted to fit into this
environment
now i should say there absolutely are
methods that current that use
the current predominant technology this
jet and air
sorting in a high bsl environment
so it's not to say that you can't
achieve a
safe operator environment with
traditional technologies
i think and the point i hope to make
throughout this presentation is that
it's simply very difficult to do that or
at least
implementing that is going to be far
more complex or involved and
um i'd like to make the case that um a
different type of system will allow you
to make that transition with a bit more
confidence and a bit more
ease so um i've touched on this a little
bit already but
bulk cell isolation methods they're very
common
in general you don't get a really great
specificity of the cells that you're
going to be pulling out but they're
incredibly useful for large amounts of
cells they're
really quite easy to transition
i think the what you gain from something
in flow cytometry sorting is
a really a high parameter sort something
that allows you to be very precise about
the cells that you pull through
and very exclusive about the the cells
that you pull through as well so that
means
any sort of contaminating cell type
can be excluded quite nicely
some drawbacks to that technique i've
already talked about the aerosolization
part um which we'll go into more detail
about but they also require
a quite trained operator to use these
technologies
um many of you probably use a cell core
or a flow cytometry core
and those are trained experts that spend
a lot of time in the morning
setting up their machines a lot of time
at night shutting them down and then
we'll be monitoring them throughout the
day so this
it can be a prohibitively difficult
technology to take on into a lab that
doesn't have the expertise
so in the interest of kind of getting
everyone on the same playing field i'll
do the classic intro speech where you
talk about the webster's dictionary for
a hazardous sample
it's really what you think it is it's
something that has the potential to pose
a risk to
the safety of an operator or something
that might contaminate the system itself
and we'll see that both of those uh pose
significant risk when you're talking
about something as
infectious as covid or as uh scary as
some of these
bsl three and four microbes that
individual labs are working on
we're going to try and keep this focused
more on the the
in covid 19 sars kova ii
uh world in the interest of staying on
topic today but uh these same sorts of
uh ideas and technologies apply for
hazardous microbes or plasmodium uh
really pretty much anything that uh you
would you would deem scary or hazardous
so quickly i'll go into a bit more
detail on
what a traditional jedinair sorter does
to separate the cells and how
we mitigate the risk to the operator as
i mentioned this is something that is
done
plenty of cell cores flow cytometry
cores excuse me operate
uh with this type of technology but um
the uh infrastructure to do so is pretty
significant
so a jet neurosorter very briefly the
way that it works is it pressurizes the
cells
in a device
that pressurization shoots the cells out
of a nozzle
into the air at which point uh cells
that
have the desired phenotype are
they have a charge applied to them which
allow a magnet to
physically separate those cells in the
air
in the theoretical perspective i'm
always fascinated at how well these
systems work
um it's actually quite remarkable how
far this technology has come
from such a seemingly impossible
type of engineering technology so i've
always been quite impressed with this
the the difficulty here is obviously
that you're you're spraying cells
through the air
in a space where humans are trying to do
their science as well so
the way that that's mitigated is whole
sorting systems are placed inside of
biosafety cabinets which
can help minimize the amount of aerosols
that actually make it into the room
these cabinets also will have
specialized air handling systems or
aerosol capture systems um operators
themselves can be required to wear
ventilation systems
this is something everybody's quite
familiar with
now um and really the part that uh
always was more of a mystery to me is
the decontamination of the instrument
and the housing
um if anyone has spent a lot of time
with a cell sorter
this type of cell sorter you know that a
clog that goes through can spray
material all kind of inside the device
which
poses a an outrageous amount of
work to to get that clean and that's a
person who has to go in there and do
that cleaning so
under those circumstances somebody's
having to
either take on that risk or
be abundantly cautious when
cleaning out these systems obviously
microbes in shared fluidics lines pose
the risk
to contamination of future samples but
i i think it should be fairly well
understood that
um working with a system that generates
deliberately generates aerosols of
hazardous material just doesn't feel
good
and so they're
i think that's all i'll say about the
systems for now i think
i've made my point there um
when covid19 outbreak occurred
um but it was i follow a message board
online that's contains a lot of the
flow experts from around the world and
it
very quickly became the question of how
much
caution do we need to take to run this
material
and i've followed that with quite a bit
of interest
it you know many labs are equipped to do
hiv sorting and things like that but
with the
excitement about working in this field
there are a lot of people entering into
the space that may not have the same
level of expertise or the same
infrastructure and so uh
eventually we kind of settled on i say
we
the ice act the international society
for the advancement of
cytometry i believe is what it's called
they settled in on some recommendations
for
operating with the cover 19.
the cover 19 patient samples they
can be safely sorted in a bsl2
laboratory with certain
bsl three level practices in place
during the sort
in general an aerosol management system
and respiratory protection for the
operator at all times when the cell
sorting chamber is opened
and an sop detailing procedure in the
event of a nozzle clog
so i've already gone into a little
detail on these things
this is the recommendation from
the nih and the isac biosafety committee
so
this is uh as real as it gets for
how we've been asked to operate under
these conditions
um i i think this is
an obvious thing to implement for groups
that are deliberately working
on covid19 samples i think it's
a reasonable practice
in labs that are working with human
material
to operate with some level of caution or
assumption that
it's possible that infectious material
is present in any blood sample so
as much as i'd like to think that every
sample that comes from your
blood donor facility is clean and
happy and healthy unless you're actually
testing for that before it gets into
your facility
taking precautions like these is is
probably safe
so here's a little bit more granularity
on these
details we want to test containment of
the pre-sort using a cyclexd
procedure i'll go into a little bit more
detail on this as we talk about
aerosolization
uh this is a test to verify that your
system
is uh able to contain aerosols
and minimize that spread into the room
um i've also
highlighted a couple of other things
checking the room for negative airflow
tyvek body full bodysuit gloves and
shroud with hepa filtered papr to be
used at particular times during the
sorting procedure
so really you can imagine operators are
going up quite
substantially and um this needs to be
done in a very
uh a room dedicated to this type of
research um so i hope this is
becoming more clear that it it's not a
trivial
setup to get these things moving
um this is from the isec isac
president and um from the the university
of pennsylvania
medical school and um
let's see what what is the particular
point i want to make here
um many of this
is deliberately set up such that you
have
minimal operators working in the actual
room um but there's there are
parts of working with these instruments
that require somebody to be
uh physically next to the machine but um
the uh
the operator will obviously have all
this ppe but in the interest
of not counting up everyone usually
in this case they have asked the
individual who brought the sample in to
to sit in a remote location and and
guide the sorting experiment
from elsewhere so there are systems that
um have been put in place that that help
make this work and
they are mostly based on
strategies that have been developed for
working with hiv and other infectious
diseases
okay so i think i've made this point
already but just
uh so that it's very uh abundantly clear
um flow cytometry is a
hands-on and it requires people to be
involved
and uh jet and air disorders are
potentially hazardous due to their
requirement to produce aerosols to
function
so we're really looking to find some
other technique to do
flow sorting something that gives you
the same benefit of multi-parameter
sorting
but allows you to do so in a fashion
that can be implemented in a
facility that maybe wasn't originally
designed to do that
so obviously this is a good opportunity
to bring in the the maximum title sales
order this is a
mill tennis product we've
collaborated with a group called owl
biomedical
that is based out of santa barbara we've
since moved
all of the device manufacturing to our
germany site
and uh this is now a full melt any
product the the title is a really
exciting machine and it when i joined
miltoni a few years ago
this was really what brought me to the
company um i
really just see a lot of elements of
this that
are quite transformative to the field
i've spent a lot of time on droplet
sorters and
the amount of the things that bugged me
about droplet sorters are
really addressed with this system so
quickly i'll try and do a little side by
side on
how these things are different the
maximum tito
is uh let me actually quickly go back um
this the device on the right here uh the
instrument
is a cartridge-based system
and the way that it works is you would
add your material into a cartridge
so generally and particularly in a
hazardous
uh sample or something you're meant to
keep sterile
uh any addition to the cartridge will be
done in a hood a
very commonly closed situation
that cartridge once it's closed is
presumably safe to use and i hope i can
make the case that
we we don't see aerosols coming off of
this cartridge at all so
handling this outside of the hood is
something that we've deemed is
certainly better to work with than
an aerosol device so once the cells are
placed into the cartridge
they are then dropped into the the cell
sorting device the title
uh this is a benchtop instrument it's
really quite a small footprint compared
to
an enormous biosafety cabinet with the
sorter inside of it with the fluidics
that are attached
um there's no on-board fluidics
everything the only liquid is really
what you see in the cartridge on the
left side there
the system's microfluidic-based and it
will
use three lasers and up to eight colors
to differentiate cells into
some populations that you may find of
interest and then when you designate
which cells you'd like to use it will
pass through a microfluidics chip
into your positive sort chamber
no waste is generated anything that's
not sorted
goes into what we call a negative
collection chamber
and i'll show you a little bit of the
benefits of having
the ability to hold on to that material
as we go on
so in the context of how this differs
from conventional sorting
these cartridges are single use so
there's no carryover from
sample to sample so you don't risk
contamination of your
current samples of something you sort of
previously
everything is stays in this closed
system
we're not having to apply a charge to
cells or
launch them through the air so that it's
generally considered safer to cells
and we have quite a bit of experience
investigating downstream assays that are
i think quite compelling to that
statement um and really in the context
of
uh this environment um keeping the cells
in a closed chamber is really
advantageous and
uh once the chamber is placed into the
title um we
it's a hands-off sorting procedure for
anecdotally i've run this machine
drove into a facility took the title off
a truck
set it on the bench top uh had it
sorting within
an hour of the truck parking in the
parking lot
and then um ran a presentation while
this
system was sorting and came back to
sorted material
so the ability to operate this machine
without
sitting there and monitoring it is
incredibly valuable especially if
you are in an environment where you
don't necessarily have a super
trained flow cytometry expert
in with respect to hazardous samples
the closed cartridge i think is
easy to internalize why this is
beneficial
we don't need special air handling
systems or biosafety cabinets
um but the cleaning is really
uh potentially not even a thing
because the single-use cartridges can
just be thrown away at the end there's
no
internalization of liquid into the
device everything stays within the
cartridge itself
um for i don't know how much you can see
on
my camera but this is the cartridge here
so they're
definitely small they're also robust we
did some testing with
dropping these on the floor in a flab
facility and checked aerosol and
still nothing or anything like that so i
think it
unless you have a step that requires you
to bash your cells with a hammer um
we would really anticipate that your
cells remain
inside this chamber uh for the duration
and that
incredibly minimizes the requirement
for cleaning of the system itself
the cartridge has these lure locks on
the top this is
familiar for people who've worked with
sterile blood products or
things like that and the way that the
system's pressurized is via
air going through a 0.1 micron
hydrophobic filter
and so that is uh
plenty small to keep out just about
everything
and um i think in the testing we've done
i've been
really quite impressed with how little
um or how sterile this really keeps the
machine
or your samples excuse me um
from an uh operational perspective
i i'd love to go into more detail about
how much awesome tech this cartridge has
but in reality
all you do is take off the cap and put
your sample in one side
and then put the cartridge into the
title and it kind of does the rest
so we used to have all these slides on
detail of the different cartridge
elements and they're really not that
profound i mean there's
uh a lot of the really exciting parts of
the
the heart of the system comes in the
microfluidics chip
so the cartridge itself is merely a
vessel to try and get your cells there
and again this is a single use system
and it's the the only liquid in the
whole
platform so this is really quite nice um
i mentioned plug and play this is really
once you load the cartridge and put it
into the the title system
uh it will automatically align for you
we have these
marks in the microfluidics chip that
allow it to um
align the laser spots you see these uh
three crosshairs the
red blue and violet across the the
middle channel there
um those are the the three laser spots
and
um so as a as cells pass through this
channel they're interrogated by the late
the lasers
the system will validate which cells are
of interest and then they open up a
valve which is located on the right side
we have lots of cool videos on this on
our website
that will allow passage of your cells of
interest
so this is there's no droplet break off
that you're trying to stabilize
there's no uh maintenance or upkeep that
you have to monitor
it's really once this is set up it's
really quite stable so
again this can be really quite operator
free
okay so really it's cool that we have
this device but
how has it been used in research that is
probably actually what's
interesting um this is a kind of a brand
new paper that's come out
from the nih and i believe it's the
rocky mountain national laboratory
which has gotten quite a bit of press
lately but um
their motivation for acquiring this
device was being able to use
a sorter that they felt confident about
in a bsl3 setting
and that would give them the opportunity
to evaluate potentially doing bsl4
cell sorting which um really isn't a
thing
in today's world um so
this paper i think is it's a quite
simple paper from a science perspective
but
it it shows that um what the common
problems are with
the cell sorting in this environment
i've already gone to a lot of detail
there
but briefly i'll mention which ones they
were particularly concerned about
these are this is paraphrased from the
paper itself
that a lot of times this material is
hard to come by so loss of cells
is particularly damaging as a limitation
of a traditional sorter
aerosols are obviously a big problem and
any additional needs would be a sterile
sorting process
so anything downstream you can be
confident is going to
uh grow out without contamination and
then
easy maintenance and decontamination so
obviously in these facilities anything
that's coming into contact with
a hazardous material can be potentially
hazardous and so the everything needs to
be disposed of so
systems that run on a sheath solution
that you know you're going through
leaders and leaders in the process of
setup and shutdown and operation all
that has to be disposed of in some
manner so working with a system where
all the waste you generate is this
the that's really quite beneficial
so i've talked a lot about aerosols but
not how we test for them so
this is a a very common aerosol
detection setup the cyclix d
is the name of the disposable device for
for checking out aerosols and basically
they're these yellow green beads
like one micron size that they use to
qualify if these are escaping from a
particular device
um the these pictures are taken from a
a draft like an internal um
setup that we tested at miltenny um
this is i believe going to be published
somewhere maybe from a
poster um basically
in short this was set up on the taito
and we ran a few experiments
and really we couldn't detect any
uh aerosols being formed at all
on the title and in fact it was so few
that we actually had to use an
atomizer to generate enough um
of these beads to actually get a signal
so we could determine that the
instrument was or that the
cyclexd testing was even working
properly
um so in the positive control we can
definitely see these uh
red circles in figure b um indicating
beads
and in the uh positive or in the
negative control we see uh no beads
this is as expected and then uh in
figure d
um this is our actual experiment we
don't see any beads as well
and this is nice but the
caveat is always like well yeah miltoni
did this experiment so why would we
publish
i mean as a scientist i hate that
response but this is
the reality of working at a company now
is people always have reservations about
our own data so
um it felt really good when the rocky
mountain national laboratory
ran a very similar experiment in their
facility um
trying to replicate this data and
they took fluorescent beads and very
similarly they ran them on the title and
on
their current system which is a
droplet-based sorter
in all fairness the aerosolization
uh mitigation
uh i can't think of the name the ams
system was pulled off
of the the aria so i don't think this is
a totally fair
representation of aerosolization on the
aria
but um the the point that i like to
point out is that really
in testing on the title in a 10 minutes
placed inside of the actual device we
see
absolutely zero beads being captured and
this was tested across the entire
coverslip
obviously there's just representative
images here but the the entire coverslip
was checked on the title ones and it
it did not show aerosols so um
i think this is as good a proof as any
uh i'm convinced by this data
um the group also
as part of that paper ran a trial test
on
sorting some something quite basic uh
pulmonary t
cells and um i i won't go too much into
the detail here but
i think it shows that they were able to
sort
well within their expectations or
normal parameters for sorting um and
interestingly
when comparing activation of the t cells
which is usually a response to
um other cells present or some
other stress involved with the sorting
or
other application or assay process um
the tor the title sorted samples
actually have lower activation
than those purified with magnetic beads
which i think of as being
particularly gentle already so
they tracked this back to probably being
due to not having quite as pure of a
sample that came out from the magnetic
particles but
just showing the uh the power of having
a more specific
sorting device or something that allows
them to get to a more pure final
product
this is probably the most exciting part
is we've started to
implement this device into facilities
that are actually looking to do coven 19
sorting and i
[Music]
want to point out a group at university
of chicago
who have a a title cell sorter and
i'll actually just read through this
part here um
i i have to give a plug for a future
webinar that's coming up soon i
we have some of this data in-house but i
um
i was told not to present it right now
and instead to let
a member of patrick's lab do the actual
presentation there in the interest of
kind of
having an expert talk about this data
and so the
uh that data can be found on an upcoming
webinar please reach out send me a
message
if you'd like to have an invite to that
webinar
we are happy to have people join that
and it will be
displayed in a context that i think is
done by the right person to
present it that said i'll read quickly
through his
um uh talking point on using the actual
title
um we have used the max quantitative
cell sorter to sort
b lymphocytes from blood donated by
individuals who have recovered from
covid19
we found the title much quicker and
simpler to use than traditional cell
sorters
furthermore the sterile cartridge
allowed us to safely sort our bsl2
plus materials at our campuses flow
cytometry facility without any issues
the low pressure and gentle microchip
sorting mechanism maintains
high cell viability which enabled us to
easily perform 10x genomics on very rare
populations of cells
obviously this is a pretty generic
statement on the title uh i really
uh think most of what he's saying is
everything it confirms what i've seen in
the field as well
and um i'm seeing research like this
come out
is always redeeming because i know
what the system can do and seeing it in
the hands of people that are
experts in the immunology side um or in
the infectious disease side is
um always a great feeling so
again quick plug please reach out to me
i will
get you connected to the actual data
that's come out from this experiment
and i'm really quite excited by it
all right so now getting into another
group that's used the the title in a
coven 19
context this is a group in denmark
that has used
the taido to work on an
antibody treatment and they
have used it in a similar context i
think this slide is
so interesting the picture that they've
put up here because
[Music]
there's sort of a gut reaction to seeing
people in a lab
facility without gloves without a hood
without
masks um working
on a sorter that's sorting infectious
material
and um there's
a lot to be said about that that i think
the
instrument has provided enough
confidence to them that they're
they know they're working in a contained
device and
that was deemed to be safe for them to
work in
uh and even a bsl1 setting um in denmark
so
this is uh something you'll want to talk
with your
eh s about for sure but i think there's
precedent to believe that
this uh sterility and containment is is
really
um quite different from what we would
expect on a normal cell sorter
all right these are statements from an
interview with this group
uh that melting conducted and um
we were curious about are the b cells
themselves actually even uh
hazardous anymore if a patient's
recovered from
coronavirus um and so
they basically just treat them as if
they were infected still so
that means uh transitioning this work
from
uh actively infected to post-infection
doesn't mean that they transfer
their hesitation on working with this
material uh
to a lower level of containment
they really still consider these as
hazardous even after
um the the patients are recovered
so we can imagine there's gonna be a lot
of individuals who've recovered from
this disease that um
will have interesting medical questions
to inquire about and i think there's
reason to be cautious that when working
with any any of that material
um okay let's get to this one
so in here they say they actually are
they feel safe moving
samples from bsl-2 or even bsl1 because
the system is fully closed
the droplet formation
systems need to be in a biosafety
cabinet or bsl3 due to aerosols
it really just changes the entire
infrastructure of how they were able to
do this type of research
and i'll be excited to see what comes
out from their
actual culvert research so we've
done this uh chat with them they're kind
of just getting going on taito
this lab is a hiv focus lab primarily
but
with the world in the state that it is
they decided to switch to
covid research we will i'll show some
slides from the hiv side where they had
developed some of the title work
which i think will give some context
into how they plan on using this in the
covid
side as well again
safety is by far and away the major
benefit according to them
it doesn't require in-depth training
this is particularly good for groups
that don't have a lot of experience
on cell sorting systems and if you you
want to be as hands-off as possible
and then finally there's uh
no issue with containment and
the operator burden of any sort of
cleaning and
is really a lot different so with that
i'll move into some actual data on their
hiv
sorting and real quickly
their experimental design was
getting hiv-positive blood from an
individual
and this is not fixed material this is
actually
hiv-positive blood and they would do a
magnetic enrichment for cd4 positive t
cells and then staining for cd45ra and
ccr7
and sorting on the the maximum tidal so
i would say this is a pretty standard
workflow for individuals investigating t
cells in infectious disease i think many
of you have probably
have similar types of
workflows for taking things to the flow
core
so sorting these t cells out i mentioned
earlier that there's no waste that's
generated so
getting material that's from an infected
individual is often quite difficult
and that material becomes very precious
so putting it through a cell sorter
that will spit anything that's not
sorted into a waste chamber
that goes away forever is really
undesirable there are
strategies that can help you minimize
that but here everything stays in the
cartridge until you
yourself pull it out with a pipette so
what they were able to do was
uh sort multiple populations from the
same material
and um they did that by simply taking
from the negative
sort chamber and then placing that into
the
the input side to sort out the next
cell type so from this they were able to
get effector t's central memory t's
naivetes and terminally terminally
differentiated t cells from the same
set of material so that's just one blood
sample
the first question i always get in
response to this is what about the
viability of going through the chip
multiple times
viability after sorting is in the 99
on all of these and um
this is something i've seen across a lot
of different materials
so i'm of the impression that um
sorting through this devices
it's often more damaging for the cells
to just be in single cell suspension at
all
versus going through the chip itself so
most of the time viability issues are
due to the sample preparation side and
not do the actual sorting
and um i think this is a pretty good
indication of that
we were able to get great purities out
of each of these even for
uh fairly low uh starting percentages i
guess 14
is not that low but i think the next
slide will
hopefully shine a bit more light on that
um
so i think this is
this data is meant to show that the
title
is a comparable sorter from a utility
perspective to what you're
used to working with um i i think as
the field has um
seen these sort of new technology
sorters come and go
uh there's always been drawbacks to
using them and
most often they were issues with
throughput
or difficulty from an operator
perspective
or they didn't have quite as many
parameters
that really stymied the ability of these
instruments to really kind of influence
the field at all
but this data i think indicates that
normal types of sorting experiments can
be done here
and you can get uh yields that are
the same or better we have a new high
throughput cartridge that runs twice as
fast as our first cartridge so
i think we're absolutely comparable if
not better
from a speed and yield perspective
purity is
absolutely achievable up to 99 plus
percent
you set up your experiment the right way
um
and the ability to sit and let it go
without having an operator sit there
but is really transformative and
i i hope that this is enough to at least
put that idea
uh out there um we have a lot of
research
that's been done that's being done on
this um i'll go into a little bit more
on
really the the breadth of this
technology to sort of validate that
okay yeah it's contained yeah it's not
generating aerosols but
is it really as good as working with the
traditional sorter
uh can i really implement this into my
workflow
and so um what i'll show you uh here is
uh information from an antigen-specific
t-cell sort that's been done as part of
a
therapy and um this cell sorting i think
the material starts at like
point one percent of the targets yeah
i'm realizing i
didn't put that on this slide but um the
antigen-specific t-cell
sorts are always with very very low
starting targets
um and they're able to pull up to 94
purity
in a single sort so these are um
this is a workflow that's being
implemented in a clinical trial
currently
so i'll touch on a couple other things
but i want to come back to that point
too
lots of different cells have been sorted
on this device obviously when you come
out with a new machine
you just have to get it out there and
start trying a bunch of bunch of
different things
but whenever this device has found its
place into a core
that's a great way to get introduced to
lots of different cell types
and what you'll notice is that a number
of these examples have a variety of
different sizes too so
ips cells are usually quite large
t cells are everything can sort of t
cell but
uh bacterias will sort well parasites
uh really if you come up with it we'll
we'll give it a shot
um i think there's
more and more evidence to show that this
can be a more of a swiss army knife than
i think we
even we expected um
a lot of this talk has been geared
around
sterility and integrity
of your sample and keeping that
contained into a device
and um i think operator safety
is a huge part of that but i think
what's really
validating to our ability to do that
is the implementation of this device in
the clinic or translational work and
in this context we're
integrating into a system where
samples usually pulled from a patient
some sort of
either viral transduction or
enrichment of some kind some sort of
culturing occurs where we're
either giving extra power to the immune
system or
uh culturing up the immune system so
that it's
more present in the tumor environment
um and then going back into patients and
so
to be able to get into the regulatory
discussion
of is this product
clean enough sterile enough to go back
into a patient
there's a an extensive amount of
qualification
that has to go into that um and
i'm excited to say that the title has
already been used in this
environment it's part of phase 1 and
phase 2
trials actively right now over 200
patient samples have been sorted
over 50 of which have already been
provided and infused into patients
and this is expecting to expand into
even more trials this year
um and ongoing into the future so
um but i i think
i felt it was necessary to include this
into this presentation because
i think nothing can speak more
tightly to how enclosed
how clean this sample
is and how uh
defended it is from other cell types
getting in there from other contaminants
getting in there
and therefore things getting out um
than being in a clinical setting and so
i i'm really
excited about seeing where the cell
therapy world takes this device
um and i think it's just a really great
example of
um just how enclosed this system is and
how
safe we really think it is for an
operator
um yeah i i think uh
i hope that this set of data encourages
you to
to look at this device and think about
it how it might change
your perception of doing cell sorting
with
material that are deemed hazardous again
i
i think this is a way to take this type
of work into a place where
you may not have the expertise right now
and um
we've we've already placed this uh new
placements for people that are
angling into the covid uh research
landscape people that may not have
access to
um an infectious disease core somewhere
where they actually have the
ability or expertise to run in this
environment
and i look forward to
engaging with any questions you might
have in response to this i think
something that i've learned about
working in this job
is um i i know a lot about our system
i know a lot about what we've done i do
my best to get informed about
what questions people are asking but
until i
interact with people i don't know
exactly
how to support every single type of
research
i think these types of engagements are
really exciting to
to learn about what it is you're
thinking about
and our team is dynamic enough that
we're
actively responding to questions um
it's something that i think at miltoni
we have the
the luxury of being a private company so
we can kind of put our research into
wherever stephan milton he sees fit um
at the behest of our marketing team and
probably our sales team too
but um it's a company that's
based really on innovation and his uh
kind of life's mission is to make cancer
history and so
this uh context of covid
provided a really nice platform to
demonstrate how quickly we were able to
respond to
questions in the field and address these
uh issues of oh my god we'd love to work
with
covid patient material but we we don't
have the faculty to do that right now
so with that i will wrap up i i've
already kind of gone over the
conclusions but i i'd love to take
questions from you
but i have my email address right here
i'll put this disclaimer up
yeah i guess i haven't read through
every detail there but um
please reach out to me my email's right
here my phone number is here
i'd love to answer any questions you
might have on this or
see what i can pull from our company to
to help you
we have gmp materials we have
application data we have an application
development team
if you're working on new materials and
also reminder please reach out to me if
you want
an invite to the webinar on the
university of chicago
b-cell sorting for covid samples because
i think that's
going to be a awesome presentation as
well so
with that i'll sign off thanks for
joining me for
the uh not quite an hour um but maybe
that'll give you a little extra time to
grab coffee before the next thing
yeah thank you for joining me and i look
forward to hearing your questions
and i will hopefully talk to all of you
soon thanks